la parole est à notre collègue alain
milon pour le groupe l'est républicain
et pour deux minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame marisol
touraine
madame la ministre comme il fallait s'y
attendre
le conseil constitutionnel a invalidé
une partie de la mesure phare du projet
doit de santé que vous avez présenté aux
assemblées en cette fin d'année la
logique que juridique contredit à bon
droit la logique politicienne
j'avais souligné en séance dès le départ
que le tiers payant généralisé me
semblait répondre davantage à une
volonté gouvernementale qu aux besoins
de nos concitoyens et aux évolutions de
notre système de santé
concernant les personnes les plus
fragiles nous avons toujours été
favorables au principe du tiers payant
fallait-il le commuée en une punition à
l'endroit des médecins qui voient là une
nouvelle façon d'attaquer la médecine
libérale
elle va à l'encontre de deux libertés
indissociable de la qualité de notre
médecine celle pour le patient de
choisir sans médecin celle pour le
médecin de prescrire librement le
conseil constitutionnel a jugé qu'il en
irait autrement et les médecins s'en
réjouissent madame la ministre
ma question est la suivante allez-vous
vous conformer à la raison dictée par
les sages et revenir sur l'idée du tiers
payant généralisé où allez vous
persévérez envers et contre tout merci
pour vous répondre la parole est à venir
la vie des affaires sociales de la santé
marisol touraine devait la parole merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
président alain milon nous avons eu des
débats intéressants fructueux sur la loi
de modernisation de notre système de
santé je salue d'ailleurs l'implication
de
vous-même et de la commission des
sénateurs sur ce texte
mais le tiers payant n'est pas une
mesure qui résulte du bon vouloir de
telle ou telle c'est une mesure de
justice sociale dont les principes ont
d'ailleurs été confortée par le conseil
constitutionnel monsieur le sénateur le
tiers payant ne portent atteinte
évidemment ni à la liberté par les
patients de choisir leur médecin
ce principe est réaffirmée dans la loi
ni à la liberté par les médecins de
prescrire ce qui leur paraît bon et
nécessaire pour leurs patients
ce principe est lui aussi ré inscrire
dans la loi qu'a dit le conseil
constitutionnel que le tiers payant
pouvait se mettre en place
au rythme et selon le calendrier qui
avaient été définis c'est à dire qu'à
partir du 1er juillet prochain les
personnes qui vont le plus souvent voir
leur médecin parce qu'elles sont prises
en charge à 100% par l'assurance maladie
notamment les femmes enceintes ou les
personnes malades de maladies chroniques
que ces personnes pourraient bénéficier
du tiers payant intégral comme cela
était prévu pour les autres à partir de
l'année prochaine de 2017
le tiers payant s'appliquera de manière
obligatoire progressivement sur la part
remboursée par l'assurance maladie et
les médecins décideront s'il le faut ou
pas pour la partie remboursés par les
complémentaires santé donc le système
que nous allons mettre en place a pour
objectif d'être le plus simple possible
pour que les médecins se disent que ça
vaut vraiment la peine de s'engager dans
cette direction là dont vous le voyez
monsieur le sénateur le gouvernement va
mettre en oeuvre cette politique cette
politique de justice sociale et qui
préserve les principes fondamentaux de
la médecine libérale
monsieur le président alain milon le
ciel président madame la ministre
notre recours était quand même bien
fondées puisque la décision du conseil
constitutionnel repose sur l'argument
suivant et je cite le dispositif est mal
encadrée et le législateur a méconnu
l'étendue de ses compétences
ceci nous conforte dans l'idée qu'il
nous faudra un gros g7 loin nous la
remplacerons par le contre projet
élaboré en concertation avec les
médecins que nous vous avons soumis ici
dans cette enceinte au sénat et que vous
avez méthodiquement malheureusement
rejetée merci monsieur le président